the NFL is figuring it out and here this
is funny Chris because I'm gonna peel
back the curtain a little bit on the
industry that we're in when when
momentum starts to build towards
something big happening the the
producers and editors who supervise the
insiders start pushing them and prodding
them to come up with something right you
got to have something you got to have
more we got to push the envelope we got
to move this story forward and yesterday
it was starting to look like we're gonna
have a new CBA what we've been putting
out items over the past few days that
were aimed at getting people comfortable
with the idea that it's coming yesterday
mid-afternoon Mike silver of the NFL
reported that owners had been summoned
to New York for a meeting related to the
CBA that momentum is there toward
getting it done and then last night boom
chef tee drops the bomb that the
playoffs boss under the new CBA would
expand from 12 teams to 14 here's the
thing ESPN reported that on Super Bowl
Sunday it was buried in a longer item
about the CBA meetings in the NFLPA
holding a vote on whether or not to go
to 17 games it was their right way and
his day it was a bullet point in the
article so this has been out there but
nobody noticed it so hey hey smart work
by ESPN to dust that off and present it
as something new even though it isn't
the point is this and now I'm going to
put the curtain back in place 14 playoff
teams instead of 12 will be part of this
new CBA if and when it's ratified
nobody's really paid attention to that
because we've been so caught up in 17
regular season games so I ask you Chris
Sims as a preliminary matter your
reaction to the news that now instead of
the 1 seed in the 2 seat having a bye
right out of the gates in the wild-card
round the 2 seed will be playing the 7th
seed and only the 1 seed will have
wildcard weekend off well I mean as you
know I'm very conservative slash
traditionalist with like football and
stuff like this I know you know I've
made it be known that I don't really
want 17 games you know I didn't want I
didn't like when I heard that it was
gonna be like 8 teams in each conference
right that might go to the playoffs that
was being
bounced around for a little bit I'll say
this I could deal with this I could live
with this I actually think I like it the
more I think about it
okay though I well the first thing is
this to give only one team a first round
by is gonna make the regular-season
which is already very important and
intense compared to other sports that
much more important I mean it just takes
one more team off of the fight for a
first round bye
which will add to better competition and
teams being under pressure more to get
that first round bye because as we've
seen here in recent history teams with
the one or two seed in that first round
by we're talking about their chances of
getting to the Superbowl are very high
so I just think it from that the
competitive nature there it makes it
more fun for the regular season for
everybody to jockey for that first round
bye and also I don't think you're
flooding it I can take one extra team
you know I think okay you have a lot of
years there's the years we look at the
schedule in the standings and we go ooh
that team was a playoff team and they
missed out you know now this year I
don't know if we really had that but
most years we do and I'm okay with that
and I think this will add some good
fanfare come wildcard weekend and the
rest of the place yeah and I agree with
you the number one seed becomes even
more important if that's the only team
that's getting a bye because that team
will have played one game before getting
to the conference championship assuming
they win the the Ravens know firsthand
that that's not a guarantee right but
when you consider Chris the fact that
seven straight Super Bowls have been
played by teams that had first-round
byes and four of the seven Super Bowls
have been games involving to number one
seeds yeah I think that when they make
this change I'm done saying if when they
make this change to 14 if we have five
straight Super Bowls where it's one seed
versus one seed and we see what an
advantage it is for that team not the
week of the divisional round game but
the week of the conference championship
when they're hosting the two seed right
which will have played two games already
I think what's going to happen is
fans and media are gonna start saying
let's just go ahead and finish the deal
here and go with 16 teams and the owners
would be like well if you insist because
they recognize that expanding it to
eight games of playoff football wildcard
weekend is going to be worth even more
money than going from four games to six
games
yeah well that that's where it scares me
because that's where you drowned out the
product all right that's where a seven
and nine Denver Broncos team gets into
the playoffs and they weren't a playoff
team this year so I don't like that
they're you know they're they're pushing
the limit to the very edge with me with
seven teams in each conference now your
point about the first round by is very
real you're right you know I think if we
get three four or five years down the
road and we find that Wow it's been the
first seed verse the first seed in every
Super Bowl then there's issues and they
got to figure it out and I don't know if
I necessarily like the fact of going to
a team sure conference but you're right
this is probably a bit of a master plan
to get people to say that I hope that's
not the case and like you said the
number one seed can lose we've seen
Baltimore do that and when we first
started you know you know back 2000 you
know really when the Giants went on
their room we saw a number of wild-card
teams right who went to the Super Bowl
and made runs throughout the playoffs so
I don't think it's crazy here we're just
in a little stretch right now with the
one and two seats are dominating I don't
know why that is I don't have a reason
for it but I do think that's the number
one negative to me Mike you hit on that
does scare me that it's just gonna be
number one seed version number one seed
and the Super Bowl year after year after
year and I don't necessarily like that
either and you know the other thing
about going all the way to eight teams
per conference and and we can't say that
the regular season would have played out
this way because being aware that their
playoff berths on the line and maybe
going into that last weekend you've got
a different approach and you know wise
did there were four teams tied at seven
and nine so you know you're still gonna
have wherever that cutoff is there's
going to be a scrum for that last
playoff spot and what it does Chris by
expanding the playoff field it pulls
more teams that otherwise are out of it
into the conversation I know to have rel
seven games late in the year and that's
part of what the NFL is looking for here
even though a lot of these stadiums are
sold out in advance you want people to
show up in late December and if their
team is still alive they're more likely
to show up and spend too much money on
beer and too much money on you know
merchandise and food and everything else
you need people to actually be there for
those games and there's a list of all
the time get it and you know number
seven seeds for the last ten seasons I
don't like it though
I just I don't like that as far as you
know what you're saying first off first
out I think Audrina kind of drowns out
the product if you get too many teams
involved in the playoffs in the
conversation I know we're in the era of
like hey everybody's got to get a blue
ribbon and you know I understand that
everybody's gonna get a trophy it's fair
but I mean I just I don't I don't want
that and I honestly still half the teams
aren't gonna make it instead of twenty
not making it 16 don't make it 16 do if
and when they go to an 18 per Conference
playoff format which I feel like is
gonna be in the next CBA after this one
but we go into the playoffs every year
okay and really most years we look at
the field and right now it's 12 teams
and we really only go hmm these three or
four the only real teams that can win
the Super Bowl most years that's really
what we do we went into payoffs this
year and we basically knew we were like
alright the 49ers the Ravens right we
knew that we knew Kansas City was in the
conversation and really you know I think
New England might have been the third
the fourth team this year I don't know
if we were all in on Green Bay I think a
lot of us were hesitant on Green Bay so
to me to add another team to that
conversation let alone let it be like an
eight seed or a seven seed in the NFC
against a two seed and now a two seed
who might have lost a tiebreaker right -
in a really close game or whatever and
didn't become the 1 seed their team gets
extra beat up and of course gets
endangered more with injuries and things
like that I worry about that hurting the
quality of the playoffs on that as well
and and see that's the thing it's not
about it's not just about you know the
idea that you get forced to play another
game and you you you yeah even if it's
gonna be like I mean I'm trying to make
my point here and I'm having trouble
with it this relates to going
the rest of the way and moving to 16
teams even if the 1 seed will be a 20
point favorite over the 8th seed yeah
making the 1 seed play a game that's the
point I knew I'd finally get yeah you
have to expose your guys to injury you
have to get ready for that game you
don't get a week off so you're not going
to be as rested as the other teams I
mean look at it this way the Chiefs this
year if they had this sound' seed in
play they would have had to play the
Steelers wildcard weekend and they
probably would have beaten the Steelers
right maybe easily because duck Hodges
versus Patrick mahomes we love you duck
but Patrick mahomes um but but yeah the
Chiefs
you know when it comes time to play in
the conference championship game you're
carrying around that fatigue yeah
carrying around possible injuries that
come from the game you didn't have to
play that's where it becomes rust
disadvantage to the to seat and
necessarily an advantage to the ones a
huge disadvantage for the 2 seed and
even the mismatch like you're talking
about the Chiefs the Steelers one thing
we know is the Steelers still got
defense right and they can hit you and
they can knock your head off and then
all we get in that game we're a team
where we go uh they were ugly 7 to 9
this year or whatever and they're in the
playoffs and yeah they knocked Travis
Kelce you know out because he was over
the middle and he got crushed and now he
can't play the next week and that's
where I worry about it I worry about bad
teams affecting the teams who have
earned the right to be in the cream of
the crop I guess is what I'm saying here
and I don't even given Sunday I know
right and that's where I think and
here's and remember we brought this up
during the playoffs we love to see an
upset we love to see chaos but then
after the chaos were left with a team
that has no business being death right
right that we're deprived of The Clash
of the Titans and and this is what I'm
wrestling with you become the number one
seed in each conference and everybody
else has to play in the wild-card round
and it creates an even greater advantage
to being the number one seed what it
also does is it sets this stage for one
versus one in the Super Bowl and
everybody else has a chance and maybe
sometimes the 1 seed will lose but work
still gonna get more often than not the
two best teams from either conference in
the Superbowl and when the Super Bowl
arrives we were gonna like that we're
not gonna like it during yeah because
it's gonna be less uncertainty less
surprise less less you know sense of of
compelling football and any given Sunday
and all that but we are gonna like it
when we're getting ready for the Super
Bowl
well yeah III hear you there cuz you're
right we want to see the Super Bowl you
want to see great verse great like you
made up a good example right like it was
really cool back in 1994 to see the San
Diego Chargers upset the Pittsburgh
Steelers right to have the right to go
play the Cowboys in the Super Bowl or
that was uh that was they know the 49ers
alright but when the game was over and
the Chargers won you went ah the
Chargers have no chance of beating the
San Francisco 1,400 really like it
inevitable you felt like that Super Bowl
was like we just how many are the 49ers
gonna win by they gonna win by 10 are
they gonna win by 30 what is it gonna be
and ultimately what they win by 23 49 26
something like that so yes that scares
me
and it does you know that greatly tips
the balance like you're saying between 1
and 2 and you know again you know I just
it's it's yes we like to see one verse
one in the Super Bowl but one verse one
isn't always the best matchup you know
some years the number two seed truly is
the best team and maybe their best
player got banged up for a few weeks and
you know then they ended up tying the
number one seed but lost the tiebreaker
and man to like be 13 and 3 and lose the
tiebreaker and be the 2 seed you know
and then have to go play on wildcard
weekend I don't know if that necessarily
seemed right to me I I'm having a hard
time too I guess digesting that part you
can chime in if you choose on Twitter
we've got a poll question and we have
framed it as how many teams do you want
per conference six or seven or eight and
six is the landslide winner so far get
it not that it matters not that we care
I didn't vote six who's voting on my
Twitter account I didn't vote
this although I I would probably vote
for six 62.7%
but in second place is 8c that's the
thing seven feels like a half measure
that is temporary
just like seventeen regular season games
is temporary we're gonna have eighteen
regular season games and sixteen playoff
teams and maybe more NFL teams by the
time it's all said and done which is a
separate can of worms because there
aren't enough quarterbacks to go around
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports